[Music]
over the past few decades coffee culture
has transformed a mundane cup of joe
into an elevated experience one
influenced by brewing techniques and the
origin of the beans themselves now one
company is adding a few other
ingredients to the mix such as diversity
inclusion and sustainability nancy chen
has the story
something's brewing on the first floor
of this building tucked among the
warehouses of industrial brooklyn
the complex and caffeinated flavors of
vietnam
carefully roasted to their chocolate
caramelized peak under the watchful eye
of sarah nguyen
oh this is heavy it's 30 pounds okay
there you go pour all in pour it all in
all of it as the ceo of new and coffee
supply nguyen says timing is everything
just one minute can make all the
difference for these beans oh
that does smell really smell the sugar
sterilizing not the sugars during a
really pop
so we're currently now at a 410 degrees
fahrenheit so when it's hotter it's
developing much rapidly at this point
checking because every 5-10 seconds will
change the profile of the beam nguyen
knows the importance of striking while
the bean is hot when the self-described
activist entrepreneur started the first
specialty vietnamese coffee company in
the united states four years ago coffee
from vietnam was both nowhere and
everywhere
i didn't know that vietnam was the
second largest grower of coffee beans in
the world yes and honestly nancy i think
it's because of lack of transparency how
so so when vietnamese coffee leaves
vietnam the label doesn't say product of
vietnam or vietnamese coffee beans it
just says coffee
with only brazil outpacing it vietnam
exported about 3.5 billion pounds of
coffee in 2020 alone most of it mixed
into commercial grade blends and while
vietnam is the world's largest producer
of the robusta bean the vast majority of
high-end specialty coffee is created
from a different species the arabica
bean
what are some of the misperceptions
about vietnamese coffee people wouldn't
use words such as
cheap disgusting nasty rubber tires to
scrap the robust to be but really that
experience or those descriptions it's
really rooted in the production not the
variety if you've pushed an entire
industry into an instant cheap coffee
production you're gonna get a lower
quality product because you're selling
for a cheaper product
a perception and process roasters like
nguyen and others are trying to change
by embracing the robusta bean
robusta beans have up to double the
caffeine content of arabica robusta
beans also have up to 60 percent less
fats and sugars than arabica so what
that means from a flavor experience is
you'll get a much more dark chocolatey
nutty bold and low acidic coffee with
robusta beans
when coffee supply is part of a
burgeoning shift as more specialty
vietnamese coffee companies open around
the country well i think we're in the
very first early stages of robusta as a
specialty
beverage jonathan morris the author of
coffee a global history says much of
arabica's appeal has been in how it's
processed with robusta left out of the
picture what we're beginning to see is
well what happens if we try those things
with robusta will that make a bit of a
difference will that create some
specialty beverage and with a coffee
history spanning 500 years morris calls
the increased awareness a new mindset
and approaching that morning cup of joe
this is a lot of thought to put into a
cup of something that you normally drink
uh when you're not thinking that clearly
yet
yeah there's a little thought involved
there's a little work involved but it
pays off uh you know it pays off for you
both in terms of what you taste and in
terms generally uh hopefully of what
you've achieved by your purchase and i
think that is something that is becoming
more and more important to consumers
for nguyen it wasn't just the
mass-produced vietnamese coffee that
left a bitter taste in her mouth but how
the farmers themselves are impacted
vietnamese coffee historically and
currently has always really been pushed
into the instant coffee market or the
cheaper commodity coffee market and
because they don't have visibility
representation they can't really
advocate for better that inequality
became a driving force in starting the
company both of nguyen's parents fled
vietnam as refugees after the war but
most of her family still lives there
today
a 2016 trip changed the course of her
life when the then documentary maker
connected with a farmer and family
friend
their idea to celebrate vietnamese
coffee by cultivating better beans
my producing partner and other farmers
to talk to they're like how come we
can't be a part especially coffee
because the industry kept saying you
don't belong and so he had never
actually exported to united states he
felt so proud that his coffee beans made
it to america
today the beans roasted here are shipped
to all 50 states the company says the
revenue has grown by 24 times in just
two years nguyen says she now partners
with three farms paying workers a higher
rate for the more labor-intensive
process
she's also hoping to import vietnamese
coffee culture a slow-paced ritual
influenced by french colonization
one in appreciation of every last drop
in vietnam you actually eat breakfast
first and then you go to a coffee shop
or or cafe stand you have your coffee
alone like it is its own moment the
coffee is traditionally made as a single
serving using a vietnamese coffee press
known as a fin filter and served with
sweetened condensed milk
i love how easy it goes down
it's smooth it's very very smooth
while the company continues to roast and
refine the flavors of vietnamese coffee
rin goes beyond the drink it wasn't
about the coffee i mean it is but it was
really about this mission for me to
bring visibility representation to such
a historically marginalized community
and one that had been completely
rendered and visible for its massive
contributions to the global coffee
experience like i felt like there was an
injustice there for me to write through
developing our own supply chain and then
of course through storytelling and
connecting people and bringing people
together through coffee
a community spanning thousands of miles
getting together over a cup of coffee
for cbs saturday morning nancy chen
brooklyn new york
i love everything about this story but
where is the coffee name bring it to me
bring your coffee give me the robusta
i'm in it
more caffeine yes yes sign us up win
coffee all right good stuff